(soft music)
[Gabriel] This is Huanchaco.
This is my hometown.
Huanchaco is a small
fishing village
that is north of
the city of Trujillo
and it's a very rich place
in archaeological sites.
There has been a
continuous occupation
in this area for
more than 3500 years.
Local fishermen are still
fishing in the traditional ways
using reed boats so it's
really something that
have that magic sense
for this town.
One of the problems
we have in Huanchaco
is that we are losing that
traditional knowledge.
If we lose these sites,
you will never
learn what happened
three thousand years ago.
I think that when I was
already seven or eight,
I was very sure that I wanted
to be an archaeologist.
It was really a
very unique time.
You play with your
friends on the beach,
you help the fishermen,
you just spend time walking
around archaeological sites.
We are currently
working at seven sites
in the Huanchaco area
and the main goal
of this project
is to learn more about
how these common people
built up as a society
and transformed over the years.
When you learn about Peru,
you always hear
about Machu Picchu
or the Nazca Lines.
That's very important
but we want to learn not
in the big temples,
we want to learn what
happened in the small house.
You get a big picture
of how society worked
and that's what we want to do.
One of the problems we have
is urban expansion is
really destroying many sites
and one of our goals
is actually to protect
and to study the sites
before they get destroyed.
One of my dreams is to
have people from Huanchaco
becoming archaeologists
and working in the area,
getting them involved,
giving job opportunities
but at the same time,
feeding their own identity,
their own cultural background.
It opens also an
opportunity for local people
to learn that protecting
archaeological sites
is very important.
Coming back to a place like
Huanchaco and working here
is for me like
returning the favor.
We need spaces for people
to learn more about
their own past.
The real importance about
these small sites
is that we can link the
past with the present.
We can really tell, you know,
you are not only
just a fisherman,
you're a person
living in that site
that has more than
three thousand years
of cultural continuity.
That makes you very
unique in this world.
(soft music)